samsung's galaxy s22 ultra is currently
breaking the tech internet because this
is the first time in a while that i
think samsung knocked it out of the park
with the design and feature set they've
been improving their 108 megapixel main
camera but the major advantage comes
down to the additional 10x space zoom
lens which is something that's simply
not possible on the iphone right now the
new s22 ultra can go down to one hertz
refresh rate compared to 10 on the
iphone 13 pro max not only does the s22
ultra have a higher 1440p resolution but
you can now finally use 120 hertz at the
same time samsung is now advertising
1750 peak brightness compared to apple's
1200 nits but in terms of the
performance i'm a bit disappointed with
the new snapdragon 8 gen 1 ship because
it's miles behind the a15 bionic in the
iphone and the same thing goes for the
graphics performance as well and there
are actually some really awesome iphone
features that you just can't get on a
samsung flagship